by rather head and Audrey and Ed's going
to take us through one of the shrines of
the game so I'd take it away all right
here we go we're gonna what we're
calling the shrine free which you know
it's not really it's not really a three
years just the third we're showing today
yeah so I'm finally I'm excited I
finally get to do some play here if it
did a lot of talking today the so we're
outside the woodcutters cabin and I'm
gonna come in his house yes because I
can one mark the great thing about this
game is you know you can really looking
off in the distance you see all these
places these are places we can we can go
to and so I'm gonna map get a closer
look here where were you you were up
there I'm gonna mark it on my map just
may be safe all right so I want to check
it out we're just gonna pass by that
really suspicious looking thing you know
I want to grab that pot lid though
needed that Paula you did and of course
you know these pop-ups that you're gonna
get for your items you know don't freak
out it's just it just happens because
you know this is the first time because
we're all rebooting these things so it's
not it's not going to happen every time
everywhere all the time so what's
shaking up here checking we're hanging
out
there's something ugly by sleazy sparkly
standing in yo yo shall we do it oh you
see when you played winwaker might
recognize these little guys so this is
our is our second one we see today marks
this might be her was it it's a core ask
regardless yes they're all over the foot
are all over the place hapless you're
[ __ ] so I'm gonna head over to this
map marker that I've had I'm grabbing an
apple I'm my crap to not apples mocking
you don't let him get away with it bleep
out there so definitely else
dunno and I'll wrap the axe hey it's a
woodcutter's cab and you know it would
be good to get the wood comes back yes I
mean you could you know chop down a tree
with any bladed weapon you cannot have
it's not that just I just wanted to know
where I work this is my acts of you so
here we go woodcutters axe there's so
much less steely than I am respectable
okay this is one of the really cool like
sort of abilities to interact with the
environment here you see the streets got
a couple notches on it you know you
started out that way no I'm gonna take
out my trusty dandy woodcutters back so
I'm gonna give it a couple flax
check it out this is gonna be cool but
it's also it's not just the so that was
how you do it because I had my hips
pointed the correct way because I'm
practicing your baggage but you know I
mean you can you can sell these things
in a different and any direction and you
know not an automatic that wouldn't work
for it she's not gonna be the bridge to
your doom what it is i mean i always get
so nervous be so careful walking a
tightrope oh alright you hadn't even
check it out we had faith in you hey
guys hi guys here come here I want know
how to put your show it out
almost almost think good enough with
these guys Oh again there what's that I
guess bear give me a while off that okay
where your mama was a he nuts oh I know
really talking is unnecessary to watch
but fun pick up some stuff at Redwood
sword here alright cool your stocking
looking around quick it's more Apple
switch to a faster weapon that axe is
how it is what's a little slow so you
know it would be a little yeah lighter
of doom there so uh you got this little
areas like what's going on here and
you're checking it out it's like okay
maybe there's come a little like
neckline this thing I can you cry almost
anything he's not normal say anything
but there's a little this little deep
little plateau area over here we'll
check that out so this is a very tall
cliff you're not going to be able to
make it all up in one go so you found
kind of this resting spot where link is
going to you know re re-energize
essentially get a stand in the back get
your stamina wheel going again so check
it out it's like oh there's couple
things up there and yeah they're so
maybe that's the way we go oh yeah you
can get up to pretty high places if
you're clever about how you climb how
you use your
gemena crafty if you will get up here
I'm gonna make that lead grab that rough
room which i think is my favorite item
name thus far and look at all we got
little little line of rough rooms so
those restrooms of course we're going to
actually go into this in the next
segment e when we take an in-depth look
at cooking but if you were to cook that
it's going to have a special effect
that's going to increase link speed for
the enzyme so for instance if you were
to cook this here you've actually climb
faster and make it up here with a little
more ease which would be a way to
manipulate your stamina will be careful
without pretty low oh yes jump like you
did to get to that higher plane you're
trying to get to alright so from here we
would like to go to maybe okay I think
we can make it up there all right I'm
all about the starting jumping gotta get
though I know it's your right yeah it is
fun like each kind of a climbing segment
is a little puzzle almost like myself I
have to use your stamina like really
wisely because when you're at the very
top if you're about to run out you can
do that last leap and actually make it
up there even if you just have one
little slippery stamina you can
sometimes make it up to the top well
there we go and what do we are here
patience or not good or not Oh try Noah
dying yeah pop out a little chica slate
it's such a relief when you finally make
it into the safety of a shrine after you
know god knows what to get their
relative I mean how some strides aren't
so safe
yeah that's true this little room is
safe though this little green very safe
not ominous or foreboding at all it's
actually safe yep there we go
and now we're gonna get another yummy
ability another new room to play with
it's very cool how how they integrated
technology into this with a chicken
slave with the rooms with the different
functionalities it's it's a lot of fun
get our tips and tricks here going all
right here we are
mysterious voice nothing to worry about
stasis trial so we'll top our tickets
late in there see what we got
little droplet of technology highly
advanced stuff here yes hi Lina event oh
wow you had to I'm fired so this is a
stasis room that it's giving us and this
is going to show we're going to show
this off here what this does what this
room will do it will allow us to freeze
certain objects freeze the motion not
actually freezing freezing cold and I'll
just freeze it for a limited time though
we have to be pretty quick so you'll see
this wearing off netgear and then
there's a recharge on here so you're not
going to be able to like immediately
just pop back in that thing and so what
we got here we got you've got a big
boulder coming on down
oh we don't need our Indiana Jones
moments and you've got worries that
right there yet again and let this come
around so you can also take the stasis
off instead of letting it we're out if
you want to always immediately at it
yeah I'm gonna pick up this iron sledge
hammer here and looking over there
there's a little something-something
actually behind that where that Boulder
was comin down let's go check that out
the true hero takes every opportunity
for treasure and there you have you have
to let's check that yeah we got a little
open
so that's gonna be nice later when you
need few rupees
just tap that at the end
here you're so patient I I've died so
many times trying to go for it yeah I
shouldn't so one of the other cool
things about the state's room it doesn't
just simply lock in anything any moving
on it doesn't just freeze its motion
your what you can do is pop into
something freeze it there and then I'm
actually going to switch weapons here
and you what you can do is you can sort
of get on the stored energy into it and
once that stasis comes off all that
energy that you've built up gets
released in whatever object you you
frozen there it's now allows me to know
but you can use that in all sorts of
creative ways the game it's kind of wily
though I've had that thing fly back and
then come barreling in my face ya gotta
watch out less finger physics engine you
never know exactly think about this
thing I found back wanna go are they
gonna weigh playing with fate here is it
just gonna go because because against
the pillar your I could work so hard
words for you we can I service are on
the edges here too so but we'll go ahead
and well that's the thing that is it
really there are so many different ways
to solve a single puppy you can use a
number of up the runes to solve the same
it's true that's part of the Sun is
figuring out your way to solve a puzzle
you are way to progress in the game
he's been waiting this whole time for
you to steal his treasure you're not
really stealing it tomorrow yeah it
doesn't relieve him of his treasure yes
mr. nosy do now be arrested c'mon this
the environment just so it's so cool I
want that ambience this guy's good at
decorating
we can you find out who's the monks
interior decorator good no concerns like
what what was that something something
happened
now he's gonna go now the big man not
the big nab medium that the medium that
bacon power daddy yeah yeah pick him out
he did everything looks a little worn
out he earned it members many many years
of being in that one pose it's true that
full time it's insanely flexible so
we'll come on out of the shrine here
then we've mentioned this before but
these ruins they're not just for use in
the shrine you can use them to do all
kinds of things in the world like this
so check this out so there's this
massive Boulder hair and Picabo there's
a little something something there too
how dare it block this treasure right so
I'm gonna put that stasis lock on it and
let's let's get this thing oh come on
dad you better back watching thank you
yeah that's a pretty good luck that's
cool hated launched that a group of
enemies in this wiper mountain using so
many good well that would be sweet if
they're at least right on the horrifying
like this guy yeah you can't see it but
you killed a bunch of things i'm pretty
sure for sure yeah we'll get our trend
yes thanks travelers so this travelers
well actually has kind of a special
power to it as well so it's a stronger
its than standard easy and you have
these kind of
yes you have these different
weapons but not everyone is exact same
even if the name is exactly right they
still have different abilities all right
so I think we're moving on to the next
segment yeah and that segment is going
to be another legend of zelda breath of
the wild segment we're going to take an
in-depth look at hunting and gathering
so stick around